you are will divide up if you are on the
kind of stools or standing at the back
on this side what would you like to hear
a rap about Jesus Christ underwater
basket-weaving you may not believe this
has been suggested on three separate
occasions before because it's a
reference to it well yeah it's a
reference to Monty Python sketch which
is why people say what did you say the
back
Star Wars planets great cold you have a
particular one in mind now might you
choose fine right let's come to the if
you are on the stools or standing over
on this side watch like a rapper bicycle
pump
yeah is there something you have to
grapple with recently what do you what
do you use it because it's not just a
bicycle is it's for like sexy blow up
ladies and stuff okay cool so a bicycle
pump
starwars planets if you are on a chair
but you're on this half of the room or
like a round back what was that well
you're on the front row so that's an
irrelevant suggestion and you said it
used as you said a staunch in so not a
stanchion extension okay cool no that's
just different pronunciation that's just
different the thing is I know it's
different and he's from Wales are you
I'm not gonna pick on him he's got quite
big arms and I'm I'm tall but I'm
stringy
I so a stanchion I don't even think I
know what that is it's so kind of
upright mast is that right what is it
like a vertical pole I think I just I
think upright mast covers that
yeah cool good I like the security in
England and Wales upright mast vertical
pole it's good you know shut up
Australians dude a black straight stick
right so a stanchion or a staunch in a
bicycle pump Star Wars planets if you
were on a chair on this side of the room
or like a rapper hmm if you didn't hear
that delightful suggestion it was
Rapunzel with an afro I like it
well take one final suggestion this can
come from anywhere but make it really
good one second urinal cakes that's
pretty good and the ethics of infant
male circumcision yeah I'm glad you
clarified mail as well because it's it's
much less gross
really so you're Ryan or cakes or urinal
cakes the ethics of male circumcision a
stanchion Star Wars planets a bicycle
pump and what other we had Rapunzel with
an afro okay that's one more than
usually tape but I'm happy with that you
may need to remind me six tend to slip
my mind this lovely people of the
Aberdeen is gonna be a freestyle rap
that's a rap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions never to
be seen before never be seen again and
do not worry you'll not be anywhere near
as atrociously embarrassingly bad as you
are expecting a privately educated
middle class white boy to be let's do
this
[Music]
where to begin
maybe awesome the front you violated the
rule to give your word and her that's
fine it was forbidden for you to speak
but in this portion the front row you
were like now Chris torchin doesn't even
matter you said it wrong it's still the
wave we start the hip revised on a
stanchion you're a stand to attention
it's an upright pole and a mention I can
tie my little horse to it I can make
sure the rock reef not round fits or a
double Luke or a little double shank all
of the Scout trained and a half of that
to know how to tie things to that pole
it's kind of boring but that's the goal
we start boring and then we get much
better listen to you Ryan or make it
wetter but what is the problem there's a
mistake if the smell so bad
at a urinal cake if you don't have one
go and collect you need to put it in coz
it refreshes the scent you need to make
sure it doesn't stink and if you have no
urine or just piss in the sink if you
did that that's a real mistake and never
confuse it for a birthday cake oh no put
it on the little table Jimmy comes along
he's five years he's able to blow out
the candles he makes a wish
but sadly just get splattered with piss
he's like man what is this thing I
thought it was a pineapple ring
I've got confused when I saw this don't
worry little Jimmy boy you'll adore this
did you know if you go for a wee there's
no foreskin on your tiny penis
why well ethically in America the
country next to me where I live because
I live on the coast anyway they will get
a little boy and rip it all away they
will pay off yeah they can't resist in
Judaism it's called a bris they take a
little knife with a big cool guy in a
black cloak yeah we know
the rabbi's and they don't really care
about the ethical problems you used to
have a foreskin now you don't have one
sorry map you must feel a real chump so
blow what more skin with a bicycle pump
insert the valve in the bottom of your
bail pump it up pump it up pump it up
well stepping on the thing and you push
down hard got a bicycle with a tire in
my yard so I make sure that I'm pumping
the tire I do it so frequently that my
brow perspires I'm swearing over there
then best of all I take it to a bachelor
party a blow-up doll i inflate with that
I put it on the groom-to-be he says yeah
you're so cool see I say cool I'm ice
cold because I'm in Star Wars on a real
ice world it's the planet Hoth
yes since I was born and passed rights
back with a little torn torn cut and
open the belly crawl inside all of the
heat and the warmth that provides I like
it I like the winter season I go to a
different one all the wrong reasons I go
there get it that's it Alderaan pun
existed but now it's gone like the
foreskin
they blew her up with the Death Star in
the 3rd one year in Endor that was a
moon it had the little things little
yachts on the tree they swing if you're
not deep if you're not nerd all of these
planets you've never observed you'll
find it absurd but here we go I remake
all the Disney movies with characters
with afros Snow White she's got a fro
got a little towards here you need to
grow but then the best one yeah I want
to say you're dumb y'all if you don't
respect Rapunzel she's up in the tower
sits up there ticked about an hour for
her to care with her hair
a little bit of cocoa ba puts it on a
skin keeps it voice taught by your
mother but the afro hair products are
more expensive that's kind of weird guys
we should be pensive and think why you
set this way shops a racist I'll be the
first to say but Rapunzel she's up there
at the window prints at the barman he's
like whoa ho I'm gonna climb but there's
no follicles coming down here cuz the
curly molecules from afro-american here
means that the window and the princess
is there and she's probably happy she
doesn't want to chat climbing on a hair
ripping out of a stop he goes up there
he doesn't get his goal he probably
should have brought a vertical pole if
you want to get the princess that's the
answer when you're on your horse don't
bring a lance bring a stanchion
[Applause]